a day of
sorrow and remembrance at the armenian
martyrs memorial near los
angeles all day long families came to
pay their respects
laying flowers to commemorate the dead
but this was also a watershed day for
armenian americans as u.s
president joe biden officially declared
the mass
killing of armenians under the ottoman
empire during the first world war
as genocide i think the old armenian
community
saying like a really thank you for him
to pronounce
as a genocide so we
we so appreciate it finally
the justice is coming i'm so happy that
president biden made the statement today
and i wish my parents
were alive to hear this and see this my
mother and her family did go
through the walking through the desert
in syria they killed her
father my mother's father
my mother's youngest sister died biden's
statement said
we remember the lives of all those who
died in the ottoman
era armenian genocide and recommit
ourselves to preventing
such an atrocity from ever again
recurring
previous presidents avoided use of the
term for fear of
angering nato ally turkey and indeed
turkish officials lashed out summoning
the u.s
ambassador to lodge a protest and
foreign minister mevlet cavusoglu
declaring words can't change history
we won't take any lessons about our own
history from
anyone turkey has fiercely denied the
mass killings of one million
five hundred thousand armenian men women
and children
was an act of genocide saying the deaths
were the result of warfare
in istanbul many people rejected the
genocide label
no such thing ever happened during a war
things happen on both
sides so it's meaningless to describe it
like that
our relationship with the us is already
really bad and this will only worsen it
u.s turkey relations have frayed in
recent months as a candidate
biden declared the turkish president
recep tayyip erdogan
as an autocrat and his administration
has pressed ankara
to stop human rights abuses in the
armenian capital yerevan
people marched and cheered and the
country's leaders applauded biden's
statement
many armenian americans here say the
terrible events of more than a century
ago
are like a festering wound that never
heals
no matter how many decades have passed
we grow up
you know uh you know with with
the the stories uh that have been passed
down
from survivors the story of survival
so much trauma and it's and it's and
it's a
multi-generational trauma but some say
for them
the president's words have shifted
something
a sense of relief because it's it's out
in the open it's been acknowledged by
biden now perhaps there can be some
measure of healing rob reynolds al
jazeera
montebello california